another day of rain lightning and strong
winds as monsoon season rolls on in
southern nevada thanks for joining us
i'm denise valdez and i'm brian loftis
today's storm moved right through the
entire valley and for some neighborhoods
this was now the second time getting
soaked in the last 24 hours
ted florendo kicking off our team
coverage with what's ahead now for the
rest of the week ted hey guys time lapse
from earlier today
taken by john langler look at that pass
through from the south
you can't see through that rain because
it was coming down in moderate to even
heavy amounts
at times look at our rain tallies today
so we had rain this morning
rain this afternoon around our seven
o'clock hour 6 30 hour anthem
picked up three quarters of an inch
mccarran not too far behind
at three tenths exer preserve in
wetlands park also
getting some decent amounts there
nothing really for the north part of the
valley as most of that rain really
favored
right here the south and midsection of
the valley and then sort of died out
fizzled out
as it made its way up towards the north
so here are our current temperatures
right now 76 degrees
your humidity 79 percent
it feels like it were we in florida
79 percent your 24 hour change a degree
warmer than yesterday now there are no
storms over the valley in fact storms
have been winding down
all across the region even with that
humidity but could we see some again
tomorrow and we see improvement in that
humidity detail is all coming up in your
most accurate forecast d.o.u
ted thank you and henderson a 12 and 14
year old swept away while playing in a
drainage channel this was an anthem
henderson police say the boys were
pushed downstream before firefighters
caught up to them
and got them out both expected to be ok
but this is a reminder to stay out of
those channels and washes
especially during thunderstorms while
the rain passed through las vegas
rather quickly other parts of southern
nevada really got hit hard places like
perum
facing some dangerous driving conditions
these are telephone poles floating down
the road
come on come on buddy
unfortunately those flooded roadways
were just some of the ways the storms
have impacted that community madison
kimbrough continues
our team coverage from pahrump where
some say they haven't seen a downpour
like this
in years damage in pahrump
is extensive from heavy flooding to
uprooted trees like the one that you see
right here
in this neighborhood
[Applause]
it woke me up about 10 30 the thunder
lightning flashing all around
tom wilcox recalls the intense storm
from sunday into monday
afternoon he says the rainfall was so
loud he was worried his windows would
shatter
and as for the flooding this is video he
took of his street
he says he didn't dare leave the house
but saw some cars try to make it through
it was up about this far in our driveway
it's probably a foot deep in the road
yeah just flowing over at the pahrump
valley speedway owner chad broadhead
said it's been years since he's seen
this amount of flooding
and unfortunately the damage will cost
him and we just put a whole new surface
on this racetrack just a month ago
which cost a few thousand dollars to do
and now it's all washed out so we've got
to redo it
and as you can see behind me you can see
anywhere from 6 to 12 feet of water in
both our lower pit parking and
our racetrack so what's next for the
speedway broadhead says
at this point it's a waiting game we
cancel our races for a while
we start back in and do a complete
cleanup
we try to fix our buildings as for the
damage you can see the cleanup has begun
and the owner of this home says it could
have been much worse he's just happy
that his roof is still intact
reporting in pahrump madison kimbrough 8
news now
parts of henderson still cleaning up
from that micro burst that hit
thursday at arroyo grande park some of
the softball fields closed
because the fence was damaged this is
video from last week
also the bmx track and dog part are
closed because of the flooding anyone
who goes to the dog park should be
careful
as crews do continue to clean up that
general area